treasure why is it always so goddamn
hard to
find this is the story of The Treasure
of Foggy Mountain the Priceless golden
bust of Marie
Antoinette it was stolen from Versa by
French naval Explorer jeanpierre Lor Ro
he fled to America and hid it deep
within the mountain in his final days he
built a map a key leading to this
legendary
treasure it was his dream that the
bravest most feared adventurers in the
world would find it and solve its
puzzle that is not what
happened it doesn't
[Music]
matter the way you move
is morning my boy morning brother
breakfast time know I'm on the eggs
heads up Jeff
J A guess we're just having leftover
[Music]
Patti time to go to
work do
[Applause]
it dude the sub's busted come on man
dang
[Music]
it
[__] the [__] did you just say to us
you heard me Slender Man buy some beer
we'll beat your
ass all right bro bro you asked for it
thanks
[Music]
boys
Mark your boy's
[Music]
okay where the [__] were
you you're 3 hours late dad you don't
understand the subs was busted so we had
to shred you had to shred wait a minute
why your lips red were you eting a snow
cone it's a really good guess the police
are here and they're saying that you
bought alcohol for miners oh no yeah
that's a crime in Europe the drinking
age is like 10 they could have been
European what made you think they were
European they had a certain J CLA I
think one of them was eating pent on
shakala F I'm going to retire soon I'm
not always going to be here to babysit
you well you know what no can I stop
this for a second if you ever ever
Johnny talk to my friends like that John
yeah be some place cells right now or
I'll kill you got it see you brother uh
so I don't mean to be rude but like
lunch is usually now so could we I'll go
thank you sir skates are cool though
right God damn it would you stand still
would it kill you to be just a little
more like Dylan I mean look at that God
gu's a rock star a rockstar he's like
the most normal guy in the world he's
the best he looks like he's in the
eighth grade he's so cool try to pick up
on what Dylan has
yeah I love
you now love you too did you just look
around to see if anyone you did I just
saw you went both shoulders let's get to
work okay good talk
cool okay let's less touching and take
off the
skates